men
listen up are you sick and tired of
these [ __ ] ass
lightsaber colors like baby blue and
purple by one of my lightsabers and
become a real man right now
we've got charcoal black it's camo whoa
call of duty brown blaze orange so you
don't get shot in the [ __ ] woods
leather trust me it looks like it's just
the whip but it's actually a light saber
see anything you like uh camo was pretty
neat
hold it right there we got deluxe models
hey hot rod how about a chrome
lightsaber
bear hair a tiny flip out saber for
everyday carrying
so i showed up for force awakens in my
full mace windu
outfit and my purple lightsaber and
still i get dumped
what's going on you know my life was
falling apart when i started this
company
red they got it right the first time
freeze
got him just another lightsaber i'm
trying to get rid of this gun here so if
you want to pick me up
bacon a lightsaber this one's very
lightweight
this one's called the thin blue line it
might not look scary but look at the
bottom
it's a punisher skull and that's super
scary i was arrested at disneyland
and our new favorite saber the stealth
saber it's completely invisible
silent and amazing
yes
[Music]